أنا دانا سانتس مدرب للتنفس
والجسم الذهني في الرياضات الاحترافية ،
تم تصميم تمرين التنفس هذا
لمساعدتك على التنفس بشكل أفضل بالإضافة
إلى منحك 90 ثانية من التنفس العميق
الذي سيثير استجابة استرخاء
تساعد في تخفيف التوتر الذي يمنعه بالفعل
يخفض إنتاج هرمون التوتر
ضغط
الدم ويقلل من معدل ضربات القلب ، يُطلق عليه
، وهو نمط يعتمد على عدد خمسة
يستنشقون زفيرًا وسبع عدات وتوقف مؤقت لثلاث عدادات
وسنضع
أيدينا وأضلاعنا
لتوجيه ومراقبة
حركتهم  لذلك هذه الضلوع السفلية
هناك انقسام هنا لأنها
مصممة للتحرك
لذا سنستخدم أيدينا للمساعدة في
تسهيل تلك الحركة
التي سنستنشقها داخل
أنوفنا ونخرج منها ،
فلنبدأ بالزفير للحصول على
أضلاعنا في
وضع جيد ، لذا دع الهواء يخرج
الآن ، سنأخذ ستة أنفاس معًا
لمدة 90 ثانية عند هذا العدد 573 ،
فلنبدأ في الشهيق
ثم الزفير
[الموسيقى]
الآن توقف مؤقتًا  الشهيق الجيد
الزفير
وقفة
الشهيق ، تحرك أضلاعك للخارج ،
الزفير ، تحرك أضلاعك
للخلف وللأسفل للسماح لكل الهواء بالخارج ،
توقف
شهيق
الزفير ، استمر في التوجيه ومراقبة
حركة الضلع
في الخلف والأسفل عند توقف الزفير مؤقتًا ،
فقط حافظ على الوضع ثم استنشق
الضلوع تتحرك  بهذه الطريقة زفر
الضلوع تتحرك في الخلف والأسفل ، اترك كل
الهواء يخرج
مؤقتًا
[موسيقى]
يستنشق
الزفير
وقفة للمرة الأخيرة ، هذا هو
آخر أنفاسك
ممتاز ، لذا فهذه 90 ثانية وفي 90
ثانية ، ثم
ننتج استجابة الاسترخاء تلك التي
تجعلك تشعر بالجهاز السمبثاوي  الجهاز العصبي
الذي يستريح ويعيد النظام لبدء
الاستجابة
، لذا نأمل أن تشعر بآثار
ذلك أيضًا
عن طريق تحريك أضلاعنا أثناء تمرين التنفس هذا ،
فنحن ندرب أنفسنا
على التنفس بشكل أفضل بكفاءة
وفعالية أكبر